[Musique]
on désamour on se lave ou nous a blessés
du soir au matin
j'envie les autres même lors des forts
je voulais être n'importe quel gamin
les grands revers
ph
à 100 tu meures
le temps c'est zé ton jolivet
et je n'ai jamais dis je
martin s'est immiscé que tu as or
continue d'y croire encore et encore la
joie c
thomert et noailles et et ardent pas ça
ce que tu as
c'est soigné ségur conte à caceres
[Musique]
ce que je veux
mais noyé désir d'en passer
ce que je peux
c'est con à caceres
[Musique]
les plus brefs j'ai foi en l'air s'est
présentée de vue un certain jetons tard
et jockeys corps
pour voir cette même si sa tatin je vais
pas finir avec ses névroses brûle de ta
jalousie serait aussitôt mais tous nous
sommes bois mais pas ce sont à nouveau
des sièges passé
tu aimais est noyé tr temps passé
cheveux
cette poignée c'est clair qu'on a cassé
ce cash passé
noyer désir d'un passeur
c'est con à caceres
à
[Musique]
mais pas
l'agent
m
j'avais
je t'aime
[Musique]